foreign
this is part of what we would typically
describe as an Aftershock sequence in
the aftermath of a major earthquake so
after an event of this size magnitude
7.8 earthquake about two weeks ago it is
very much expected that there will be a
sequence of earthquakes in the weeks and
months following that
[Music]
in a case of a very large Main Event
like our 7.8 earthquake in this case it
produces a very large area where faults
that were nearing preparedness for an
earthquake are pushed beyond that
breaking point and so in the in the
weeks and months following a large
earthquake we can expect these events to
occur again hopefully in a gradually
decaying manner so that they become less
and less severeign
[Music]
uh
typically the Aftershock sequences start
to die down after a period of days to
weeks but already there have been 7 000
or more aftershocks recorded we will
expect this to continue uh certainly for
weeks and perhaps months after this main
shock and of course buildings and areas
that have been damaged by the main
earthquake are potentially subject to
further damage associated with a large
Aftershock like this one
foreign